st
[Musique]
cette maison est devenu un vrai lieu de
débat de fond c'est aujourd'hui huit
conventions qui ont été qui ont été
tenus c'est plus de 200 réunions au
travers les différents forums groupe de
travail qui se sont tenues depuis 18
mois ça veut dire plusieurs réunions
chaque semaine tout au long de ces de
ses 18 ans il n'y a pas d'autres partis
politiques ce n'est pas en marche
il n'y a plus aucun débat sera rien ça
n'est pas au fond national n'a jamais
été leur culture et ce n'est bien
entendu pas à gauche aujourd'hui puisque
le rassemblement de la gauche tel qu'il
est fait de bric et de broc fait qu'ils
sont incapables d'avoir une ligne
coordonnées donc d'obtenir ces
discussions nous ne sommes pas une
formation politique
or seuls nous sommes une famille avec
son histoire ses disputes parfois et
surtout des liens très forts les
républicains sont l'objet de manoeuvre
politicienne de la pire espèce de la
part de la majorité macro nist et de la
part du rassemblement national parce
qu'ils voudraient rester entre eux
loin des préoccupations des français
depuis son élection
emmanuel macron n'a qu'une obsession
nous détruire ce qui ferait la joie du
rassemblement national mais nous
résistons nous résistons et nous
gagnerons parce que nous restons
rassembler et claire sur ce qui nous
unit rassembler est clair sur notre
ambition battre la majorité des manuels
macro et battre le rm en proposant une
alternative crédible susceptibles de
redresser notre cher pays
et s'est passé beaucoup de choses en
quatre ans depuis l'élection d' emmanuel
macron était inconnu sans que c'est un
garçon qui gagne à être un peu moins
connus le en marche est devenu dans
l'esprit collectif et un peu compris par
tous champions un peu plus tout et son
contraire c'est à dire c'est pas une
politique c'est dans le meilleur des cas
du statut pro c'est dans le pire on
recule et on boit dans beaucoup de
secteurs et les municipales il faut être
très très très conscient il faut le dire
il faut pas s'en excuser
et ça a été évoqué par christian jacob
de courchamp des communes de france
jamais depuis cinquante-huit un outil
politique au service de l'action d'un
chef de l'état dans notre régime
républicain a été aussi faible et je
serais même tenté de dire n'était aussi
humilié moins de 5% des voix se sont
portées sur les candidats en marche ça
veut dire quelque chose
c'est à dire que la façon dont il parle
aux français un peu partout en france
dans toutes les communes de france u20
de la rue est en totale contradiction
avec la réalité des besoins justement de
ces mêmes français et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons eu une très
belle victoire
ils ont une belle victoire ce nous
savons tout simplement les raisons pour
lesquelles nous faisons de la politique
et pour lesquels nous nous engageons
dans ses responsabilités locales et et
nous avons une belle victoire parce que
nous avons aussi une belle génération
qui je le disais se lève devant d'un
espoir et veut prendre des
responsabilités bien c'est cet esprit là
qui doit dominer pour la préparation des
régionales
je ne reviens pas sur ce qui a été dit
remarquablement je veux féliciter la
fermeté de la ligne de l'engagement et à
la fin des fins nous verrons auprès des
français que naturellement le meilleur
rempart à toute aventure de quelque
nature que ce soit comme l'adversaire le
plus déterminé de ceux qui ont une
vision au premier de notre pays est la
meilleure réponse justement à ce qui
était une aventure
présenté il ya quelques années comme
étant une belle aventure avec un ciel
bleu au fond et est une réponse qui sera
porté sur le terrain sur la base des
résultats
nous avons tenu
pas les thèmes de cadeau originale mais
la clarté c'est la condition en
politique pour créer la confiance et
cette clarté doit nous conduire dans
l'année qui vient à être présent et être
en capacité de l'emporter pour ne pas
nous résigner à ce qu'il n'y ait pas
l'espace entre eux
la république en marche et marine le pen
c'est ce pour quoi nous nous mobilisons
avec nos idées avec nos valeurs nous
sommes divers à cette tribune du conseil
national
mais nous partageons ensemble divers des
valeurs et je le dis clairement le
président macro n'est pas un président
qui a les mêmes valeurs que doux quand
il parle de déconstruire l'histoire eh
bien je dis que nous nous avons des
valeurs pour notre histoire et pour
d'autres pays
quand nous disons que nous devons
traiter la question migratoire je le dis
parce que chacun sait d'esprit yeux
plutôt ouvert que j'ai c'est parce que
il va falloir répondre sur ces sujets
avec courage réponse nationale répond ce
européenne quand on nous dit dépenses
publiques nous vous disons qu'on pourra
pas continuer que le rapport d' cour des
comptes
on y va tous ensemble dans notre
diversité c'est ça aussi les gaullistes
les libéraux et les chrétiens-démocrates
c'est ça la république à la force de
notre famille politique elle réside dans
des convictions ancrées dans l'histoire
l'histoire de notre famille puiser dans
la filiation du général de gaulle de
georges pompidou de valéry giscard
d'estaing de jacques chirac de nicolas
sarkozy nous sommes une famille
politique a une histoire et pascal une
histoire elle a des devoirs qui
conduisent un avenir qui fonde notre
espérance et je sais au moment où nous
vous parlons que vous êtes dans
l'inquiétude
dans le doute quelquefois dans la colère
et je veux vous dire notre notre
confiance
notre espérance nous y travaillons tous
ensemble ici il ya des atouts ce que
cette alternance notre pays en a besoin
et je suis profondément convaincu que
seuls les républicains avec leur
histoire avec leurs valeurs avec les
hommes et les femmes qui la composent
peut aujourd'hui l'a proposé avec succès
aux france on se parle franchement
est-ce que la tâche est facile non la
tâche n'est pas facile
ces engins comme l'a dit tout à l'heure
nous venons de passer tout nous avons
par le passé eu des échecs électoraux
importants il est nécessairement des
traces dans l'opinion les français ont
encore un peu de mal à nous regarder
mais ce travail de soutien qui est fait
depuis plusieurs mois
ce travail de fond qui te travail
difficiles à mener mais le travail
essentiel
il nous permet petit à petit de
retrouver notre crédibilité politique
il permet aux français de se dire tiens
aulas c'est désormais à droite chez les
républicains que les choses se passent
que les idées émergent et que l'on peut
trouver un nouvel espoir est ce que les
médias nous facilite la tâche non s'il
était là pour nous faciliter la tâche
nous le saurions mais nous nous battons
qui à pied je peux te dire que à chaque
fois qu'il nous faut mener la bataille
nous somme lan démultiplions autant que
nous le pouvons nous forçons des portes
qui ne sont pas toujours ouverte sommes
pas à vendre à la découpe et que nous
sommes pas soluble ni dans le république
en marche ni dans le rassemblement
national et qu'on doit tracer notre
propre chemin et qu'on doit porter nos
propres idées nos propres convictions
alors je sais qu'on a toujours tendance
parfois à nous mettre d'un côté ou de
l'autre à vouloir nous écartelée je
pense au contraire qu'on doit tous se
rassembler et montrer que l'alternance
politique il n'y a que nous qui pouvons
l'incarner et montrer surtout redonner
un espoir à notre jeunesse
tout a été tenté pour nous déstabiliser
on a l'habitude de ça qu'ils ont tenté
de faire éclater notre groupe
parlementaire il ya quatre ans ils ont
échoué lamentablement
parce que là aussi on a bien vu que
toutes les combines était et toutes les
manoeuvres étaient été utilisés eh bien
on a résisté on a résisté parce qu'on
est sur une ligne
il n'y aura pas d'accord à quelques
niveaux que ce soit avec la république
en marche
on l'a dit très clairement s'était
rappelée enseigne il n'y a aucune
ambiguïté sur ce sujet en tout cas il
n'y en aura aucune tant que je
présiderai notre mouvement et puis le
deuxième point c'est que nous avons
aussi un autre adversaire c'est le
rassemblement national avait cure ne
partage rien mais rien rien de leur
idéologie
c'est une réalité aujourd'hui ils ont
une idée en tête c'est nous déstabiliser
et là aussi nous devons être solide
[Musique]